quand je vous disais que décidément plus
rien n'est vraiment comme avant c'est
que vous savez dans la guerre que ce
livre le clan Windsor donc la famille
royale et les ce sexe donc Harry et
Megane oui c'est en permanence ça coûte
au tirer et bien on sait depuis deux
jours que le roi a fait sa voix via son
secrétaire privé Clive Alderton Clive
Alderton vous savez son petit nom on
l'appelle l'âme à la hache non seulement
qui est la résidence ou habite Harry et
Meghan qu'il a fait appelé Harry et
Mégane les équipes de Harry et Megan a
müntechi
la montagne
il a une chicharde
aux Etats-Unis
et il leur a dit que désormais voilà il
souhaitait récupérer fragment cottage
c'est un cottage comme son nom l'indique
une maison une maison de cinq chambres
précisément qui avait été offerte par
Elisabeth 2
au matin de leur mariage comme le veut
la tradition donc voilà donc la guerre
continue puisque désormais Harry et
Meghan n'ont quasiment plus de résidence
en Angleterre c'est pas totalement vrai
puisque deux pavillons étaient offerts
par Elisabeth II il y a encore également
York cottage qui est dans le norfol
Carson
en tout cas il y a pas de il y a pas de
commentaires ils n'ont pas souhaité
prendre la parole ils ont été vu hier
à Los Angeles dans une soirée
sur ma vie comme ma vitesse
sur la tête
[Applaudissements]
avec des talons
et c'est exactement tout l'inverse de ce
que veut montrer la famille royale à
l'heure actuelle c'est à dire volonté
il est un peu en situation difficile
l'énergie a plus que doublé il y a des
campagnes alimentaires il manque
d'aliments dans les par exemple on ne
trouve plus certains fruits et certains
légumes à longues choses qui n'est plus
arrivé depuis la rigueur la soupe
populaire a réouvert il n’y a jamais eu
autant de monde à la soupe populaire
bref et c'est quoi c'est chaud la robe
là Caroline
du cyclisme sur le mot Ventoux
et les chaussures étaient Christian Dior
calme-toi donc ils sont en train de
montrer ces conneries là cette robe et
ses chaussures là combien ça coûte des
infos mon fils si tu viens juste pour te
mouiller
je sens que tu lagaces vraiment combien
il faut quand même savoir Cyril aussi
que c'est prêté le troisième
d'accord et donc là ils sont binaires
parce que ils font les malins là ils
font les les ils sont très bah ils sont
très américain ils sont très people
voilà et la famille royale depuis qu'il
est qu'il a accédé au trône Charles III
a dit voilà désormais tout va changer un
peu en quelque sorte une monarchie au
pastèque et à lourd c'est un peu exagéré
mais François Hollande c'est François
Hollande voilà c'est vrai on voit que le
couronnement le budget a été réduit la
cérémonie a été réduit tout a été réduit
et dans ce cadre-là et bien choque
marketage dont on parle tout ailleurs
tout dont on parlait le fameux pavillon
qui est situé dans le domaine royal de
Windsor et bien ils ne l'ont occupé
depuis leur départ en mars 2024 trois
reprises trois reprises uniquement donc
le roi a dit ben écoutez sur la couronne
ça nous coûte de l'argent ça coûte des
frères non mais ils veulent vendre
ils ont fait 2 millions de travaux et
pareil qu'ils ont fait payer par jour
500000 € de travaux parce qu'ils avaient
un garçon
qui est la grande décoratrice en
Amérique bah c'est elle elle travaille
pour les Beckham elle travaille pour
George
c'est la grande décoratrice oui oui très
en vogue
mais il a remboursé
donc maintenant voilà et ça ne pavillon
en effet secret pour l'instant et bien
attribuer à Andrew Andrew c'est le frère
Charles vous savez on en a parlé ici
de quoi criminalité
il rigole pas donc l'énorme papillon lui
alors il est il est logé Cyril à Royal
et Lodge Royal c'est immense
chambre Elisabeth de la Clamart
mais il ne va plus pouvoir payer parce
qu'il faut savoir que si tous ces
pavillons là la disposition du roi il
faut quand même participer un peu ils
doivent quand même verser un genre de
loyer que certes très modéré mais qui
est quand même existant et surtout ils
ont à la charge le personnel qui doit
entretenir ses pavillons donc Charles a
dit que désormais Andrew que l'on voit
là donc ce serait beaucoup mieux lui
tout compte fait à frog more quoi
celui-là que à Royal Lodge si vous me
suivez absolument
on déloge Harry alors que c'est un
cadeau de mariage déjà je trouve que
c'est un scandale ça veut dire que
quelque part on bat sur
la grosse différence c'est que lui n'a
jamais comment dirais été éduqué par
exemple un médecin aussi on raconte que
et Elisabeth II a fait promettre à
Charles quel quitterait pas un truc qui
ne laisserait pas une trousse à l'auber
le chemin puisque c'était son fils
favori enfin après c'est des histoires
de famille ça reste des histoires de
famille dis-moi
euh dis-moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est un pas de
plus dans la guerre entre Harry et
Meghan et la famille royale
oui Cyril en effet on peut voir ça comme
ça puisque on rappelle qu'on est
précisément aujourd'hui à 64 jours du
couronnement tu seras célébré le 6 mai
prochain et la question que l'on se pose
tous à l'heure actuelle c'est Harry et
Megane seront-ils présents de
Westminster on a toujours pas la réponse
à cette question mais en tout cas on
peut quand même deviner que si Charles
III a fait n'a pas laissé passer le
couronnement et a fait connaître sa
décision avant c'est qu'en tout cas il
ne les redoute pas il ne redoute pas
leur réaction donc j'adront-ils
j'adront-ils pas c'est une histoire de
famille en tout cas je qui sont quand
même invités
ils sont invités absolument et qu'est-ce
qu'on vient d'apprendre il y a encore
quelques jours seulement que le bouquin
de Harry vous savez le suppléant qui
sait déjà si bien pour du bien il va
sortir en poche
on appelle ça en Angleterre on appelle
ça Penguin pinguin ça veut dire quoi et
alors bah le livre de poche et bah le
pingouin le glisse dans sa poche
et bien parce que le livre sera sorti en
édition de poche Harry a déjà dit que il
serait complété d'un nouveau chapitre un
chapitre par rapport à la réaction de la
famille royale par rapport à la sortie
on continue à faire de l'argent
ils vont dire il va dire ils vont dire
quoi la réaction de la face royale
pour l'instant il y a des réactions il y
en a pas eu des masses si ce n'est le
fait que bah on leur demande de pas si
oui parce que ce qui est intéressant
peut-être à dire aussi c'est le chapitre
veut dire ils ont demandé de dormir vous
savez dans le fond oui on ne sait rien
non
je sais pas pourquoi
vous savez quand a eu lieu ce coup de
fil de clarif Alderton aux équipes de
Harry et Megane le lendemain de la
publication du livre c'est-à-dire
et c'est seulement maintenant que la
presse voilà qu'on en a qu'on en a le
bruit ça veut donc bien dire Siri là que
la famille royale ne laisse
transparaître que ce qu'elle veut
vraiment et que c'est dans le fond la
lune des institutions je trouve les plus
incroyables de tous les temps puisque
elle nous dirige nous même si on a
l'impression
frère tu vas nous faire un navet
donc parce que je te pose toutes les
questions là j'en ai rien à carrément
aujourd'hui comment Harry Mégane sont
vus au Royaume-Uni avec Tony bohu très
mal
si le livre se vend très très bien et
qui sont en tête des ventes en revanche
ils sont totalement en baisse dans les
sondages
pour les livres
48 millions pour le livre
en finale
c'est très simple il lui donne 40
millions si Yvan pour 40 millions de
livres ils sont titard chacun
s'ils en plus tout ce qui est au-dessus
aujourd'hui
il a le bruit qui circule qu'on va être
aux alentours des 10 millions
d'exemplaires vendus
donc il doit toucher hors taxe dessus
six sept euros donc tu fais 7 fois
combien il va prendre 70 bars
qui rajoute effectivement 5 lignes pour
en ressortir une nouvelle édition et
retoucher ce type est vraiment un sale
mec c'est toujours ça pour les deux
poches
des formidable on fait toujours ça pour
les livres de Paul tu rajoutes toujours
pour la définition j'ai déjà senti un
livre et comme vous aimez le shopping
Carolina Herrera c'est entre 5000 et
15000 merci voilà bah tu me mettrais
celle-là
ils vont continuer à faire des
révélations choc sur la famille sinon
Cyril vivrait de quoi et dans le fond le
jour où ils arrêtent donc c'est pour ça
qu'on peut quand même s'attendre à avoir
Harry Meghan je n'y crois pas une seule
seconde mais Harry on te ramène
exactement
un nouveau chapitre et d'entendre
d'autres livres qui devraient encore
venir
4 livres et on en a une un seul et pour
la petite anecdote alors même que
lorsqu'ils sont rentrés au mois de juin
pour le jubilé de la reine Mégane nous a
appris quelques jours plus tard que en
rentrant à flop mortege dans l'ancien
bureau qu'elle avait elle a un peu fait
du rangement et dans un tiroir elle a
trouvé le journal intime qu'elle avait
l'écrit qu'elle avait tenu les mois
qu'elle a passé en Angleterre dans ce
qu'elle a été mariée en gros elle est
redescendu l'escalier elle a dit Harry
je viens de retrouver 40 millions de
livres ne dormaient dans un tiroir sur
un pudding je le jure sur la poutine
ouais non
est-ce que toi tu trouves qu'il cache
crache trop dans la soupe
non tu trouves ou pas oui en effet enfin
voilà oui je trouve que oui il crache
trop dans la soupe j'ai du mal avec
cette attitude non partons quelle est
les raisons qui sont invoquées au moins
de janvier 2020 nous partons parce que
nous n'en pouvons plus de cette famille
de cette inst itution et surtout nous
n'en pouvons plus des médias qui nous
Axel là directement qui ont tué ma mère
et comme je n'ai pas pu sauver ma mère
je dois sauver ma femme et mon enfant et
là maintenant ils sont présents en
permanence dans tous les médias ils en
ont besoin pour vendre des livres c'est
avec cette attitude là que je casse les
glaï oui sinon après je suis une part de
casse les Glaoui il me casse les il me
casse les glaouis
[Rires]
mais sinon voilà je le répète j'ai été
très très attendri très touché par le
livre d'Harry il a souffert ils ont
morflé en effet il faut la reconnaître
quand même oui
tu ne mets pas l'humanité qui ne met pas
l'homme au centre de tout une seule
chose qu'on tire c'est la couronne quoi
la couronne de moi